Так ліцеїсти військового ліцею імені Івана Богуна відпрацьовують дії солдата в бою.
Одна команда займає оборону, інша - йде в наступ.
Це командна військово-тактична гра.
У ній треба вразити противника безпечним лазерним променем.
Працюючи у групах, юні захисники розвивають швидкість мислення і розробляють тактику бою.
Цими та іншими вправами у Київському військовому ліцеї імені Івана Богуна
виховують майбутніх офіцерів - еліту Збройних сил України.
Із чотирьох основних складових: англомовний бандерівець, майстер спорту із золотою медаллю.
Оце де бандерівець, щирий патріот, то вже це ворог за нас зробив.
Потім на другому іде ідеологія - Україна понад усе.
Потім йдуть по складових:  йде моральна підготовка,
тобто я воїн, я буду боротися, я переможець, я богунівець, я козак-характерник.
І далі йде психологічна - долати труднощі.
Замість цивільного життя юнаки і дівчата віком від 13 до 17 років
обрали однострій та військовий режим.
Тут їх готують до вступу у вищі навчальні заклади:
дають ази топографії, домедичної підготовки, вчать долати воду і висоту, вчать стрільбі і тактиці бою.
А серед викладачів є й діючі військовослужбовці,
які пройшли АТО і зараз беруть участь у бойових діях
та діляться з підлітками своїм бойовим досвідом.
Чим цікавий бойовий досвід саме для дітей?
Насамперед, тим, що це є вже нова жива війна, яка відрізняється абсолютно від усього.
Навіть той досвід 14-15-16-17 років, він абсолютно не може порівнятися з повномасштабним вторгненням.
Тому що це є зовсім інша війна.
Тобто змінюється тактика, вводяться нові підрозділи, з'являються нові посади як БПЛА.
Вони починають розуміти, що можна, як зробити, що краще долучити до ведення,
можливо, наступальних, оборонних дій, що не варто долучати.
І з цією практикою, і з практикою попередніх війн вони починають асимілювати ці всі знання
і потім знаходити своє рішення.
Тому що в подальшому майбутні командири, від їхнього рішення залежить хід бою.
Тут щодня муштрують майбутніх офіцерів - уроками, спортивними заняттями і військовою підготовкою.
Понад 7 тисяч випускників ліцею зараз боронять Україну.
А серед теперішніх ліцеїстів чимало тих, хто походить з військових династій і змалку мріяв стати офіцером.
Бажання було ще змалечку. У мене батьки військові,
тож це, можна сказати, династія.
Виховали таке почуття відповідальності.
Для мене військовий - це приклад, це показник, як би сказати правильно,
показник статусу держави, показник рівня її розвитку.
Андрію шістнадцять. Цього року він закінчує військовий ліцей
і планує вступати до військової академії в Одесі
на факультет підготовки спеціалістів керування силами десантно-штурмових військ.
І, незважаючи на те, що в країні йде повномасштабна війна,
він твердо переконаний, що увалив правильне рішення.
Не можу сказати, що я боявся попасти на лінію фронту.
Побоювань таких не було.
Звісно, є певні страхи перед смертю, перед зіткненням, але хто не боїться, той дурень.
Кожен батько, кожна мати переживає за свого сина, за свою доньку.
Але краще я піду туди підготовлений, ніж мене мобілізують і я нічого не буду знати.
Із початком повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну
батьки почали більше переживати за своїх дітей.
Та майже всі богунівці повернулися до навчання, каже начальник ліцею.
А на місце тих, хто не повернувся, знайшлося чимало охочих.
Ми тільки за професійну роботу, бо офіцер ніяк не може бути примусово.
І чим більше нас буде не тільки по кількості, а й за рівнем мотивації,
і підготовки, і по забезпеченню, то і буде швидше перемога.
І тут не просто ж одноразово, бо ми не знаємо, як буде через місяць, через два.
Ми віримо і працюємо на перемогу.
І якщо минулого року кількість вступників трохи зменшилася,
то вже цього року їх знову побільшало -
мінімум дві людини на місце, а серед дівчат - по 5-6.
Ми на всі вакантні донабрали без проблем, тобто всі, які були вакантні, там три, п'ять, потім шість -
всі набрали, і зараз навіть резерви.
Ми не переживаємо, якщо навіть десь якийсь там… У нас завжди мінімум п'ять-вісім чоловік в резерві.
Тобто якщо хтось втратив мотивацію, ми кажемо:
добре, що зараз, бо найнайгірше, коли на передовій.
Тут ще вибір є, і в нас є резерв, ми ж за професійного, офіцери тільки за покликом серця.
Жодного примусового, це не Московія, що має бути штрафбат і "загранотряд".
Потрапити у ліцей - не так легко.
Треба здати іспит з української, англійської, історії та фізичної підготовки.
А у своїх есе під час вступу підлітки пишуть, чому вони мріють бути військовими.
І цьогоріч на їхні твори вплинула повномасштабна війна.
Що мріє бути пілотом, льотчиком, "привидом Києва", морським котиком, десантником, танкістом.
Малюють "Хаймарси", ППО, IRIS T, "Петріоти".
Зараз вже почали "Леопарди" писати, бо ми боролися за "Леопарди".
Тобто ці вже нові вступники, так?
Так, вони фанати. Зрозуміло, що в них ще поки романтика ними рулить,
але нам головне, щоб батьки їх благословили, щоб дали їм зелене світло.
Зараз у ліцеї навчається 850 богунівців.
Серед  них - 8 відсотків дівчат, по дві у кожному взводі.
Євгенія мріяла вступити сюди ще з 7 класу, відколи дізналася про перший набір дівчат.
Ще з сьомого класу, вперше коли я дізналася про перший набір дівчат,
я задумалася і хотіла спробувати.
І якось так з роками, і я зрозуміла в 9 класі, що це точно моє бажання, що я хочу бути захисницею своєї країни.
І так йшла, йшла, йшла до своєї мети.
Ліцеїст для мене - це вихована,  сильна, з великою силою волі людина,
яка вже знає, що вона прагне в житті,
вона вже знає, ким вона хоче бути.
І це є патріот, який любить свою батьківщину і готовий віддати своє життя за Україну.
З початком повномасштабного вторгнення батьки і друзі Євгенії просили її змінити своє рішення.
Проте майбутня офіцерка наполягла на своєму.
Звичайно, просили зробити якийсь інший вибір,
передумати, але я сказала, що це моє життя
і ви маєте поважати те, що я обираю.
Відповідно, вони погодилися і сказали так, справді це твоя майбутня доля
і ти можеш робити те, що тобі подобається.
І на цьому ми з ними завершили тему.
Вони мене підтримують і до сьогоднішнього дня.
Я людина, яка ставить собі мету і йде своїми кроками по ній.
Тому з початком війни нічого особливо не змінилося,
але були трохи страхи, якісь думки і друзі, які цивільні, говорили про те, щоб я думала.
Але що думати, якщо я вже точно знаю, ким хочу бути,
і точно знаю, що я хочу бути в формі та ходити у погонах.
У ліцеї переконують: їхнім учням не потрібно йти воювати у найближчі роки,
адже вони лише на початку свого військового шляху.
А залучати до бойових дій можуть лише курсантів старших курсів військових вишів,
як це було на початку 2022 року із курсантами у Києві та Харкові, які допомагали відбивати атаки ворога.
Не переживайте, кажу. Їм в атаку не треба ні завтра, ні післязавтра, ні через місяць
і навіть через рік не треба, навіть через рік.
В кращому випадку, це можливо через 2,5 роки,
де вони будуть охороняти містечко, якусь базу, бо треба не менше 2 років,
це базова підготовка, потім на третьому починається спеціалізація.
І можливо, як було, коли найважче, то залучали третій, четвертий для посилення,
четвертий, п'ятий мають бути готові до дострокового випуску,
завжди мають бути, завжди, це прописано в документах.
Зараз батьки більшості ліцеїстів знаходяться на передовій чи волонтерять.
У 23-х дітей батьки загинули під час бойових дій.
Тому викладачі ліцею імені Богуна стають для них і психологами, і родиною.
Дуже складно, тому що в нас кожна дитина зі своєю історією.
У зв'язку з тим, що війна, є діти, в котрих прямо зараз,
або вчора, або завтра десь помирає батько на фронті,
в когось брат в полоні, в когось ще якісь певні життєві обставини, хтось приходить після окупації.
Тобто, це складні життєві історії, котрі вони переживають прямо у нас на очах.
Випускники наші, от дуже багато їх зараз на передовій.
Ті, які мають найменшу можливість, от відпускають їх на 6 днів, на 3 дні, на 10 -
вони всі проїжджають через ліцей.
І це так приємно, тому що вони всі біжать до своїх вчителів, до своїх офіцерів,
розповідають щось, радяться. До цього часу багато хто пише.
Це не тільки привітання якесь там з днем народження, з новим роком. Це просто от написати "Я є", "Я живий".
А деякі випускники повертаються в ліцей, щоб самим стати наставниками для молоді.
Як, наприклад, Андрій, який вже пройшов службу в ООС у Пісках, а потім в Маріуполі.
У мій час, коли я тут навчався особисто і взагалі у часи до війни,
нас вчили так, як зараз навчають росіян.
Бути квадратними, виконувати команди і не приймати самостійно рішень без команди зверху.
Особисто я прихильник тієї думки, що потрібно зараз в сучасній армії
виховувати майбутніх командирів, майбутніх офіцерів в креативному напрямку.
Тому що в той час, коли ти чекаєш команду зверху,
в тебе немає ні зв'язку, немає, як зв'язатися з вищим командуванням.
І ти чекаєш, чекаєш, чекаєш, ти просто втрачаєш життя своїх підлеглих.
Потрібно бути креативним і вміти правильно прийняти рішення для того, аби зберегти життя.
Я навчаю тому, щоб мої випускники, будучи офіцерами,
в першу чергу, дивилися на життя підлеглого особового складу
і вміли креативно приймати рішення правильно для того, аби зберегти більше життів.
Майже 90 відсотків ліцеїстів потім вступають у військові виші
і стають офіцерами у сухопутних чи танкових військах,
ДШВ, розвідці чи силах спецоперацій.
Це свідомий вибір кожного з них, бо невмотивованих учнів - відраховують.
Моє головне завдання - вселити в них віру, впевненість в перемозі,
щоб вони стали фанатами, як я, як мені прищепили колись.
Якщо навіть так трапиться, що хтось не вступить,
це точно будуть патріотично налаштовані діти.
Серед них точно не буде колаборантів.
Це 100%. Тому що в них зовсім, зовсім інше є.
За два роки вони тут стають дорослими, патріотично налаштованими, і ці точно люблять свою державу.
А ті богунівці, які вирішили пов’язати своє життя зі Збройними силами України,
прагнуть стати майбутньою військовою елітою.
Я думаю, що перемога буде дуже швидко і вона точно буде.
Ми всі, українці, в це віримо, прагнемо всіма силами допомагаємо цьому.
А наші збройні сили вже розвиваються і я впевнена,
що НАТО нам в цьому ще більше допоможе
і взагалі для України, як кожен українець вважає, велике майбутнє.